I said this before but the reason that
you live life in my opinion is for other
people the which sounds [__] up to say
but without other people I think life is
pointless something we keep a close eye
on here is the crisis of young men in
the U.S it's probably one of the most
charged topics that we discuss
inevitably draws quite a bit a few toxic
people in the discourse on all sides but
my biggest problem with the state of
mainstream discourse is conflating
toxicity with the idea that we don't
have a serious problem a stunning Trope
of new data from the Pew research group
highlights just how big of a problem we
have one that soon could reach a total
point of no return the first is the rate
of single young men versus single young
women 63 percent of young women of young
men today between the ages of 18 to 29
report being single that is compared to
34 percent of young women okay I just
want to stop it right there because I
remember when I first read the stat I
started laughing and then I started with
homegirl and she's like how's that
possible I don't think it's easy because
young women are getting older dudes You
know despite all this talk about like oh
my God it's so disgusting when older men
go after young women um did you not know
that younger women actually like going
after older men and it's not even crazy
it's not even a weird thing it makes
perfect sense why
the reason why younger women go after
older men is for Comfort security that's
it you know we talk about how crazy
everything is economically speaking
rents increasing everything's increasing
everything's more pricey yet people
still want to live a good quality of
life guess what your average 22 year old
in college is not going to be able to
give it to you yeah he might more have
more in common with you to some degree
but the 32 year old who got his own home
was paying off his mortgage got a
full-time job could take you on trips a
couple times a year and is much more
comfortable in his being because he's
had more experience it's going to be way
more attractive than the 22 year old
who's just trying to figure it out I can
tell you this dating at 32 is the
easiest thing ever in my life now dating
at 22 was a [__] struggle
do you know how hard it is to try to
invite a girl back to your mom's place
or your run-down little apartment when I
had one not the easiest not the easiest
I sure as hell wasn't confident what do
I have to be confident about got very
little money got only a half decent job
and I'm still figuring out who the [__]
I am so of course these women are going
to go for older men so that's why I
always laughing like ew so disgusting
why would these older guys ever want to
be with these younger women because
these younger women are aggressively
going after these older guys and as a
man when you're being desired by a woman
it's actually pretty appealing it feels
good
I personally have a hard time with it
because culturally sometimes I feel like
there's a bit of a disconnect in terms
of life goals when you think about this
stat this number
I agree
it's like
ew
have you been out
do you get out of your house do you go
online under what rock do you live I
don't see what you don't see I don't get
it like do you even go out
do you hear people talk
do you see people at concerts
the people that buy the people that buy
concert tickets is women the people that
scream at concerts women people that try
to go backstage for man performers or
women performers women women are big
time consumers they like to live and
experience things and that [__] costs
money if you talk about your typical
groupie it's not a man it's a woman talk
about comedy I all my all my female
comedian uh colleagues
do not have the same relationship with
women that we do men comedians
[__] trying to find out where
we stay at
when we're going to perform next in the
city
not the women's not so much but it's
always woman often time womans hey
there's some man here and there the
majority
yeah and no matter what performer that's
the thing for comedy is what I noticed
but then if you talk about music the
groupies the term groupie is female to
me
most of the time most of the time it is
it is or very feminine yeah I'll say
this I think this has like a much larger
effect because one of the other stats in
the Purity search said something like I
think like 52 are not even interested in
trying or care to try and when you look
at some of the reasons why they feel
like uh it's too expensive they feel
like they're not good matches they feel
like Society is not good for them
whatever when you look at the mgtow
movement I remember when I was talking
about this maybe seven years ago
everyone thought it was a [__] Meme
and come to today now it's becoming more
and more where in fact for young men
it's the majority majority of them now
that they've subscribed to mgtel or
going their way but like they've just
checked out of dating and it's happening
more and more men have checked out of uh
college men are kicked out of dating and
what ends up happening is right now it
doesn't seem like such a big problem but
there are only so many older men and a
lot of these older men are married to
women their own age and so for the
younger women who want to get with these
guys they're not always going to be
available so you're gonna have a sexless
generation at some point or a large
chunk of it being without out
companionship without any kind of
intimate relationship and I'm sorry but
anybody who's been able to benefit from
the upsides of being in a relationship
the proximity to being someone to being
touched by someone you love to have
people you can actually share that stuff
with every day in a close relationship
you understand its benefits tremendously
if you go through life your entire life
without it you're missing out on one of
the biggest parts of the human
experience I don't care what nobody
[__] says about oh my God being
single is so much less stressed yeah
it's also less happiness I'm not talking
about staying some kind of [__]
shitty abuse I'm not talking about those
garbage relations preach you can speak
to this hmm the idea of being single in
comparison to where you at I don't look
too promising
just this world this world is not made
to be single the world the way it's made
is not if you live in a big city we're
in a city at all go for it everything is
going to be like everything all the
price of everything is more much more
expensive so two income is better than
one um I was never good at math but this
math I understand two income is better
than one at the end of the day it is
what it is with the chores and
everything that you have to do around
the house or stuff like that it's better
to be too
Tango
and yeah the the everything is
constructed the way the banks are work
are working if you want to adopt a child
alone is going to be a big mess
it's gonna be rough
tiring exhausting
two way better yeah definitely when you
grow up and you look at your parents and
you think it's your parents and you're
like
sometimes you're like y'all
[__] just lit
um
y'all [__] don't love each
other
and I'm not interested talking about my
parents but I've seen that happen in a
lot of families
how [__] don't love each other
and then you wonder why why did they
together
I couldn't I understand now oh now that
I mean I I'm an adult I get it now when
you get the bills and you got the kids
and you're like um I could split
but let me stick on together because I'd
rather stay together and be here and not
be as happy as better be with someone
and not happy
then be with someone with nobody and be
miserable really no not really but
that's how they think and I understand
why they would think like that just
because of the the weight of the bills
and the weight of and the burden of life
I don't agree I I want my peace of mind
but the bills is a lot listen I think
it's bad to have this conversation and
always think
well it's better than having a bad
relationship sure but it's not better
than having a good relationship
let's say you know I mean like we
shouldn't always argue by the worst
standard possible and I think that's
what a lot of people are doing this
because they've had some bad
relationships and maybe there's things
about yourself that you need to fix
maybe your selection process is trash I
refuse to believe that most of the
people out there are bad people I refuse
to believe that most of the people out
there were not in some ways good for you
there's probably listen if you're
constantly having bad relationship at
some point you gotta look at yourself
and be like maybe I'm the reason this is
all [__] up and if you want to give
up you give up but you have to
understand for society as a whole one
more so many people are checking out not
because they've tried and failed but
because they can't have a chance or they
feel like they're not good enough or
they feel priced up which is what a lot
of people say like if you don't have a
college degree these women are not
checking for you they want to be with
dudes who are in college educate a lot
of the times this is not me sitting here
saying women your standards are [__]
up for wanting to be with a college
student it's not even that because I
could understand why maybe College helps
you to understand like
he's got the same values he's going to
be career oriented he's been able to
make good Investments whatever I I if
that one you want to make that it's not
unreasonable criteria my point is I
think it's a dark place we're heading
towards that's what I'm getting at and I
I question what this is going to look
like 20 or 30 years from now you know
during the pandemic we had so many
people who just went on Twitch every day
and spent all their days gaming and
doing all this other stuff and that's
kind of carried over and there's people
who get no social interaction I want
y'all to think about what that's going
to do to the psyche of people 20 15
years from now when they're that
detached from Human connection that's
what I worry about
there's a big ass company that's going
to teach that's going to take advantage
of that and I'm going to create some Ai
and the loop is going to be deadly all
right man it's gonna be some wild times
up ahead but I just wanted to talk about
this
just because I think when you see
depression when you see self-deletians
Rising specifically in males more than
any other group possible Right men are
self-deleting at insane rates
this is a big portion why whether we
like to believe or not some people might
find it sad having a family having a
partner those are actually very valid
reasons to live on life I've said this
before but the reason that you live life
in my opinion is for other people sounds
[__] up to say but without other
people I think life is pointless without
my family without my loved ones without
the people close to me I have literally
no reason to be on this planet
none
nothing on this planet is fun or worth
it enough the suffering that's involved
if I don't have the people around me
that actually bring me joy that make
every day waking up much more easy and
enjoyable without them this is all
pointless to what make money to do what
like like there's no amount of financial
experiences that are going to matter if
I don't have people to share it with
right if I don't have loved ones I can
really experience that with and as great
as friends are friends go on with their
lives generally speaking so when I look
at people and they say well
relationships they actually are now
women to their credit seem to be much
better at adapting to the
see what I've been met there's a
difference men suffered from and more
women suffer but not nearly as much as
men
and so good for ladies I'm speaking
specifically to the dudes the way the
economic situation is shaped it's no
surprise that women want to go for older
men
like women are also struggling to some
degree financially so they're like go
why would I stay at it's another dude
who makes 30 to 40K just like me when I
got a guy who's older more establish got
a better place better car and better
looking uh there's not condemning ladies
or condemning men it's just like this is
[__] up and I felt this was coming a
long time ago and now that it's here and
it seems to get it worse
I wonder where it's all going to go
I feel like it's gonna get first before
it gets I agree 150 I